a parade to mark Lebanon's independence
day as the country lives through
unprecedented times this was a display
of civil society united against the
political system many now want to change
the protests which began on October the
17th of force Prime Minister saddle had
a view to resign but that hasn't been
enough for demonstrators they want to
see the back of the entire political
elite the entire political system the
banking system the social system it's
everyone here is demonstrating against
that and for the first time in the
history of Lebanon it is decentralized
as a revolution and it is non-sectarian
based on Lebanon sectarian Constitution
consensus must be reached between all
sides to form a government that needs to
be approved by Parliament on the one
side Herrera and his Sony bloc and their
allies refused to accept the government
that isn't formed totally of technocrats
experts and professionals rather than
politicians President Michelle own and
his Hezbollah and I say that's a coup
against democracy since they have a
majority in parliament at a military
parade earlier on Friday an admission by
both sides that a solution had to be
found I think it's pretty deep I think
it's very deep we have to eventually sit
on some sort of a table so that we can
try to reach a convergence and you know
the different views that are being
offered by the two sides so if we don't
do that pretty soon I think we will have
a problem in my opinion we have to find
a combination of political support for
any government that we formed because of
the vote of confidence that is needed at
the Parliament at the same time those
blocks that are willing to name a
government and name ministers they
should understand that we cannot do
things business as usual things are
different now
we heard the voice of the people we
respected we should respect it at the
core of the unrest is the dire economic
situation here the
of public services the constant
electricity cuts and the endemic and
institutionalized corruption that sucks
away at Lebanon's resources for that
protesters blame leaders on all sides of
the political divide independence day
there is an acute awareness of just how
dependent this country's future is on
outside forces now the protest movements
has been an attempt at achieving and
realizing some sort of
self-determination but there is a fear
amongst many the regional powers be in
Saudi Arabia or Iran won't allow them to
succeed from Allah al al Jazeera Beirut
[Music]